jean louis touraine bonjour merci d'être
en direct avec nous sur arte france
alors la campagne pour ce second tour
s'ouvre officiellement ce soir à minuit
beaucoup de remous x lion avec notamment
si je peux dire ce coup de couteau de
gérard collomb envers la république en
marche
est-ce que vous avez digéré cette
trahison tout d'abord ça n'a pas été
facile parce que comme vous l'imaginez
les personnes qui depuis vingt ans on
travaillait avec georges que l'on se
sont senti un petit peu vous avez dit
trahi ou en tout cas
perturbé par une annonce qui apparaît
c'est un peu contre nature
je vous rappelle que quand gérard
collomb était ministre de l'intérieur il
a abandonné son ministère pour venir à
lyon avec l'argument principal qui était
de dire je veux revenir parce que sinon
ce sera monsieur wauquiez et ses proches
qui vont conquérir la ville et la
métropole
et aujourd'hui il s'associe avec eux
donc il est difficile de comprendre
comment il est passé de cette opposition
à une droite relativement dure celle de
monsieur wauquiez à une coopération avec
cette même droite
donc c'est vrai qu'il y a un petit peu
de turbulence dans la place lyonnaise en
ce que le jeu des alliances aujourd'hui
affaibli le parti présidentiel à votre
avis d'une façon générale en partie
nouveau a beaucoup beaucoup de peine à
gagner les élections locales c'était
déjà le cas même avec le général de
gaulle en 1959 je crois dans les
élections municipales qui ont suivi son
retour au pouvoir
parce que naturellement les français ont
une propension à lire les équipes
municipales qu'il connaisse celles qui
gèrent leur ville leur communauté
urbaine et donc il est évident que un
parti nouveau aura beaucoup de peine à
s'implanter alors évidemment il y a
ensuite le jeu d'alliances entre ce
nouveau parti est et des parties plus
traditionnelle le résultat en sera
chacun le perçoit j'imagine aujourd'hui
qu'il n'y aura pas
énormément même pas beaucoup pas
beaucoup d'élus qui appartiennent
véritablement à la république en marche
il y aura pas non plus beaucoup d'élus
qui soit franchement investi par la
république en marche et c'est évidemment
quelque chose qui ne peut se construire
que dans la durée
donc ce qui importe ce sera quand même
qu'il y à une bonne coopération entre
les élus nationaux qui sont majoritaires
à la pluie quand marche
et puis les élus locaux et il est tout à
fait légitime en démocratie que les uns
et les autres appartiennent à des pompes
à des parties distinctes pour peu que ce
ne soit pas dans des oppositions de
blocage que ce ne soit pas des
extrémismes mettant en péril notre
république
mais dans tous les autres cas de figure
je pense que la république en marche qui
est issu en définitive vous vous en
souvenez de de beaucoup d'élus qui était
précédemment au parti socialiste ça a
été la première le premier recrutement
pour la république en marche mais aussi
de certains élus qui venait du centre
droit toutes ces personnes naturellement
peuvent bien sûr coopérer avec les
partis de centre gauche et de centre
droit qu'elle est aujourd'hui l'enjeu
national pour le parti de la république
en marche
bah il est il est délicat bien sûr vous
vous posez la question à juste titre
parce que deux n'ont pas de nom pas de
ces élections aussi mais d'un ensemble
d'élection il y ait eu les européennes
il ira dans le futur les sénatoriales
mais qui seront sous le même sort que
les municipales et puis il y aura les
régionales peut être décalés dans le
temps
quoi qu'il en soit il est clair que
l'avenir va se jouer dans les mois et
toutes prochaines années pour savoir
s'il y avait véritablement comme nous
l'espérons bien sûr un avenir à ce parti
qui est assez central qui veut essayer
de compte
et les priorités qui était hier
développé par la gauche c'est à dire la
justice sociale c'est à dire une
attention à vos préoccupations
d'environnement aux préoccupations des
personnes en difficulté en précarité et
puis des préoccupations qui sont ce qui
était dans le passé souvent plus
défendues par les élus du centre aux
droits tels que le dynamisme économique
la possibilité de progression rapide
dans un monde où tout ce qui reste
immobile et qui stagne et bien recul par
rapport aux autres donc on à la
nécessité de se donner les moyens d'une
bonne économie d'un progrès d'une
innovation d'une compétitivité d'un
certain dynamisme et il faut faire en
sorte que ce soient conjugués avait et
que l'intérêt de la justice sociale il
faut que toutes les avancées qui
pourront se faire bénéficie bien sûr
d'une façon justement réparti à tous les
français dernière question très
rapidement sur le député dans quel état
d'esprit se trouvent aujourd'hui les
lyonnais selon vous pour cette ce
deuxième tour des élections municipales
au premier tour à lyon comme dans la
métropole de lyon ceux qui sont arrivés
en premier sont les élus verts il ya
maintenant pour le deuxième tour des
triangulaires entre donc les verts
auxquels se sont ajoutés les élus de la
gauche et et quelques insoumis et puis
il y a le parti de la droite auxquelles
s'est ajouté gérard collomb et puis il y
a le le groupe de david kimelfeld et
georges képénékian qui ont irrité les
personnes ayant géré la ville et la
métropole
quand gérard collomb a été absent et qui
brigue la continuité avec tout ce qu'ils
ont apporté depuis quelques années en
termes de plus d' équilibre social plus
d'ouverture ou préoccupations
écologiques
et donc entre ces trois partis moi je ne
fais pas de pronostic
je laisse aux lyonnais dans leur sagesse
trouver la solution
il se peut il se peut qu aucun des trois
partis ne soit à lui seul majoritaire et
donc ce sera ensuite entre les
conseillers élus à ce deuxième tour ce
sera à eux de décider comment organiser
dans la gestion de la ville
merci beaucoup jean louis tourenne avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes député la république en marge
de la 3ème circonscription du rhône